allez on ouvre la page politique à
présent avec ce sondage
73% des sympathisants de gauche elle
serait favorable à l'idée d'une primaire
la possibilité d'une candidature unique
à abu semblait peu probable à quatre
mois de la présidentielle en tout cas
les sympathisants du loyer à gauche ils
sont largement favorables selon ce
sondage ipsos dévoilé hier on va voir
cela justement avec notre journaliste
web bastien goody
[Musique]
bonjour bastien alors vu les piètres
résultats dans les sondages à gauche est
ce que les récents appels d'anne hidalgo
d'arnaud montebourg à se rassembler ont
une chance d'aboutir
probablement pas il faut dire que les
initiatives d'anne hidalgo ou d'arnaud
montebourg apparaissent comme un sauve
qui peut les deux prétendants n'ont pas
encore réussi à créer deux dynamiques et
ils sont au plus bas dans les sondages
anne hidalgo qui refusait jusque là
toute primaire finalement en propose une
mais en envisageant d'exclure celui qui
est au plus haut dans les études c'est à
dire que jean luc mélenchon et de
l'autre côté vous avez arnaud montebourg
jusque-là il souhaitait privilégier à
nouveau conseil national de la
résistance
allant des gaullistes aux communistes
désormais il appelle tous les candidats
de gauche uniquement pour un programme
commun y compris avec anne hidalgo qui
le taclait quelques semaines avant
autant dire que leur stratégie apparaît
comme une volte face et d'ailleurs pour
l'instant amie anne hidalgo ni arnaud
montebourg non non le succès dans la
proposition
ça semble logique on voit mal une union
entre par exemple la gauche antilibérale
la france a soumises et celles qui
assument le libéralisme économique
les privatiser si on comme le parti
socialiste vous avez au milieu europe
ecologie les verts qui a déjà fait sa
propre primaire et qui a désigné yannick
jadot et là aussi comment des
écologistes qui place la fin du
nucléaire au coeur de leur programme
peuvent s'allier avec des pro nucléaires
comme fabien roussel même si c'est à
mesurer ou arnaud montebourg
alors on a vu le sien il ya eu ce sont
la joue beaucoup étaient favorables pour
une primaire de la gauche et puis
dernièrement cette initiative qui a été
créé sur internet qui se nomme la
primaire populaire il revendique plus de
270 milles soutient une primaire
arbitrer en dehors des partis n'est ce
pas la clé de la réussite pour la gauche
a bien droit dans cette primaire semble
surtout de promouvoir une nouvelle
candidature pour 2022 oui celle de
christiane taubira cela ferait une
énième candidature qui n'apporterait pas
forcément
d'originalité programmatique étant donné
les clivages qui parcourt la gauche
comme sur la sécurité l'immigration la
souveraineté l'économie le
protectionnisme l'europe tout primaire
se réduirait à la fin à un mariage de la
carpe et du lapin et encore faut-il que
la gauche assume de parler de certains
de ses thèmes il suffit de regarder la
dernière primaire pour l'élection de
2017 benoît hamon l'a remporté vous avez
un bon nombre de participants qui ont
refusé de le soutenir ou de voter pour
lui certains sont même allés du côté de
la macro ni je pense notamment à manuel
valls 1 françois de rugy à la fin benoît
hamon fait environ 6% et le candidat à
gauche qui échouent à un cheveu du
second tour c'est un candidat aux
primaires jean luc mélenchon avec plus
de 19% des voix merci beaucoup bastien
pour toutes ces précisions un bastien
gouly journalistes wen l'article complet
décryptage analyse à suivre évidemment
sur notre site internet arte france
point tv